this is from New York Post one-third of
us teenagers say that they almost
constantly use at least one of the top
five social media sites such as YouTube
Tik Tok and Instagram according to a
study conducted by the Pew Research
Center uh YouTube remained the clear-cut
favorite for the second year in a row
with 93% of users aged 13 to 17 logging
into the Google own site according to
the survey of nearly 1500 teens
published on Monday um Tik Tock was next
to
63%
um and that's how it all breaks down
uh
and and then uh let's say Tik Tok users
are even more hooked with 17% saying
that they almost constantly scroll
through the app each day despite it
being the first choice of
58% uh so you know every few weeks we
get another one of these
studies and the basic headline of this
study which probably has not shocked
anyone is that uh you have millions of
young people and teenagers who as the
study as according to their own
responses apparently to the survey they
are almost
constantly scrolling um they're almost
constantly on their phone and I know you
guys probably get tired of hearing me
drone on about this but I I really
really wish that we would all stop and
think about what it means like what this
actually means what does it mean to have
kids who are scrolling on social media
quote unquote almost
constantly because almost constantly
means it means basically non-stop it
mean means you are rarely doing anything
else with your
time and of course nobody denies that
plenty of kids and adults are indeed on
their phones almost
constantly but I think we don't stop to
think about what that
means because if we did stop to think
about what that means it wouldn't be
happening if we really thought about
what that means every parent would go
home and they would take their kids'
phone and they would never give it back
to them
and most parents aren't doing that which
means that they they really don't get
it they don't
understand in
fact you know I think that most most
people tend to think that uh the Young
Generation being obsessed with new
technology is kind of normal in part for
the course they're not very alarmed by
it and and and maybe it is but but the
obsession is different here because like
when I was a
kid uh the big concern then in the 90s
was about people about TV people
spending way too much and we get all
these studies you know every year or
something there'd be another study about
the amount of time that Americans spend
and young people spend and kids spend
watching
TV and uh and it was a problem people
spent way too much time watching
television but at least your television
is at home and and you have to be at
home or at someone's home to watch it
it's like a station object and you have
to go to it to uh to watch it and and
you know even if we had 100 Cable
channels or whatever it was there was
still a finite amount of content on TV
that that you wanted to watch so there
was so there were just these built-in
parameters there were these rules for
engagement there were these limiting
principles um even to that technology
that that certainly did dominate
people's lives more than it should and
still
does but the phone is different because
it goes with you everywhere you never
escapee it and the content is
infinite um like it it never ends it's
not self-limiting in any way so it grabs
hold of you and it grabs this strangle
hold of you on you in a way that is
simply unprecedented in human history
there's been plenty of technology that
has reshaped
Humanity like when cars came along and
and uh it it Humanity at that point
point verged off in a different
direction looks very different now than
it would if if cars were never invented
um but there's never been one single
device that has become nearly the sole
focal point of
existence that is what is unique
here and that's why we're a new
territory and I and I really wish that
people could see
that and I know they can't because like
I said if they did see it and understand
what we're dealing with they would take
drastic
action to protect their kids from what
is currently happening to them and I'm
not exempt from this as a parent you
know as you know my kids don't have
phones they don't really have any Tech
um outside of the one TV that we own and
share as a family and uh because I'm
just I just refuse to let phones take
over my kids lives and and you know what
uh there there people say well if you
don't give the phone to your kid then
they'll be alienated from their friends
and and uh and that's not entirely wrong
I mean my kids have friends but and they
are a little bit alienated from them and
and as like my kids get a little bit
older you feel this more and more you
see this more and more that they don't
have that shared kind of frame of
reference like for all for most kids
their whole frame of reference for life
is the
phone and so then my kids come in and
they don't have they're
totally they they have no access to any
of that and so they don't have that
frame of reference and you can so it is
a little bit
alienating um which I don't like I wish
it wasn't like that but it's it's a
sacrifice that is worth it right now my
kids might not see that it's worth it
they don't see that but I'm the adult so
I'm supposed to be able to see farther
than they
can and uh and I
just am absolutely dead
Set uh in my conviction and my wife's
conviction that they are going to have a
childhood whether they like it or not
they're going to have a real childhood
that is not consumed by the phone
keeping your windshields clean is always
a pain especially in the winter dirt and
salt pile up and washer fluid just can't
get the job done that's where my friends
at windshield wow come in to save the
day windshield wow is an Innovative
windshield cleaning device that uses two
magnetic cleaning paddles one on the
outside and one on the inside of your
car to clean both sides of your
windshield all from the outside all you
do is push around the outside paddle and
the inside follows automatically leaving
your windshield squeaky clean we get a
lot of rain here in Nashville which
leaves you with a hazy and dirty
windshield throw one of these in the
back of your car so you can always have
a clean windshield I personally own a
windshield wow this is one of the best
products for my car windshield be able
to clean both the front and the inside
at the same time as a game changer I
wish I had one of these years ago the
windshield wow applies firm cleaning
pressure it's super thin to get into
those tight dashboard areas so what are
you waiting for go to windshield wow use
cod Walsh a checkout for a special
discount that's windshield wow.com and
use code Walsh are you struggling with
the back taxes or uh unfiled Returns the
IRS is escalating collections by adding
20,000 new agents you know in these
challenging times your best defense is
to use tax Network USA with over 14
years of experience tax Network USA has
saved their clients over a billion
dollars in back taxes no matter your tax
issu size the experts at tax Network USA
can help you they specialize in
negotiating with the IRS and aim to
reduce your debt significantly tax
Network USA doesn't just negotiate they
protect your assets from IRS seizures
and manage your yearly returns for
ongoing compliance importantly they are
licensed to help with all state tax
issues regardless of where you live in
the US seize control of your financial
future now and don't let tax issues
overpower power you contact tax Network
USA for immediate relief and expert
guidance call
8552251729 turn to tax Network USA and
find your path to financial piece of
Vine that's TN
usa.com Walsh the point is we we you
know we do have we we've introduced a
little bit of this stuff uh very very
sparingly so so we do have uh we have
tablets for the kids uh with with just
games and books on them there's no
internet access and the rule is that on
long car trips they can use the tablets
not the whole time but like that's some
that's a you know that's a it's a
resource we can use in Long card we take
a lot of long cards trips we're talking
you know talking 18-hour car trips type
type when I say long that's what I mean
and so in those kinds of contexts like
they they have the the tablet uh for
limited times that's what we've mostly
regulated it to relegated it to recently
though we started to get a little bit
more uh slightly more relaxed about it
slightly and so we would let the kids
for very limited times use the tablets
in the house and and this is always you
know it's like no one has exempt from it
as a parent you're always like okay this
is okay we're we're not doing this and
then you're like okay we'll do it okay
we'll do it but only in this context and
then then quck this is how it always
works with the tech stuff
um so but it's you know so every once in
a while so maybe total in like an hour a
week total of where they're on the
tablets in the house but not on the
internet and then a few days ago my
youngest son was using the tablet very
briefly in the house uh and uh we told
him that tablet time was over over and
he had a little bit of a
meltdown when took the tablet away and
I've never seen this with my kids before
this was like this this drug addict
withdrawal response from Tech never seen
with my kids first time I've seen it
with other kids all the time this very
common you know this is how other kids
respond you take away the video game
take away the phone and they Just Lose
It First time i' seen it with one of my
kids and it was after just a little bit
of
exposure and it it was a very you know
it was a uh it's one of those uh I
thought I was already awake to the it's
kind of an Awakening moment but although
I thought I I was already pretty aware
of the problem so I took the tablet and
threw it in the trash and that was it
and I've been thinking ever since like
man if my kids can become that attached
to the tech from having such a limited
access to it um what's going on with so
many these other so many of these other
kids I mean it's it's scary like a just
a little bit it just has this
pull and if you're not careful that's
how it consumes your kids
life I will say my wife was a little bit
annoyed that I threw the tablet away
though admittedly she's like you could
have just put it in a drawer you didn't
have to throw it in the trash
well you you got to be a little more
definitive and dramatic sometimes as a
parent it's it's and and also this is a
I come from this is like a this is a dad
tradition that I'm that I'm carrying on
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there